Bitte schön.
Okay, ja.
Guten Tag.
PAKA ist mein Name. Ich bin momentan der Diensthaber in der Arzt.
Ich bin für Sie da.
Kurz zum Ablauf.
Ich stelle Ihre persönliche Daten nach Fragen, dann Ihre Beschwerden.
Und am Ende eine Information über die Familie.
Sind Sie damit auch verstanden?
Ja, ich bin einfach verstanden, Herr Doktor.
Ja, also, wie heißen Sie denn?
Mein Name ist Ottmar Hitzfeld.
Okay, können Sie bitte Ihre Vornahmen und Nachnahmen bestabieren?
Ja, Ottmar ist geschrieben mit O, T, M, A, R.
Ottmar.
Und Nachname ist Hitzfeld, H, I, T, Z, F, E, L, D.
Hitzfeld.
Ja, danke, Herr Hitzfeld.
Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 77 Jahre alt.
77, ja, und wann genau sind Sie geworden?
10. März 1944.
44.
Okay, also, wie groß sind Sie?
Oh, ich habe mich lange nicht mehr gemessen, Herr Doktor.
Ich war einmal 1,75 m, aber ob ich immer noch so groß bin,
habe ich nicht mehr.
Und wie viel wiegen Sie?
Ja, so etwa 65 kg.
65 kg.
Ja, okay, danke für die Informationen, Herr Hitzfeld.
Also, was kann ich für Sie tun, was zu beschwerden haben Sie?
Ja, Doktor, ich komme, weil ich hohes Fieber habe und Schüttelfost.
Und wie Sie merken, habe ich, kriege ich auch nicht mehr so gut Luft.
Ab starken Hustenreiz, der war am Anfang trocken,
aber jetzt habe ich auch richtig Auswurf.
Und das ist der Grund, warum ich jetzt zu Ihnen ins Krankenhaus komme.
Es ist gut, dass Sie gekommen sind, Herr Hitzfeld.
Also, seit wann haben Sie sich beschwerden?
Also, das Fieber ist heute Nacht aufgetreten,
also gestern Nacht auf heute.
Da hatte ich auch Schüttelfost und der Husten geht so ungefähr 3, 4 Tage schon.
Am Anfang trocken und...
Jetzt habe ich Auswurf, ja.
Okay.
Also, ja, haben Ihre Beschwerden plötzlich oder langsam angefangen?
Welche Beschwerden meinen Sie jetzt, Herr Doktor?
Zum Beispiel dieser Husten.
Der war relativ plötzlich, würde ich sagen, also von heute auf den nächsten Tag.
Okay.
Und ja, wie sieht Ihr Auswurf aus?
Die Farbe und die Beschaffenheit?
Also, bräunlich, schrötlich bräunlich sieht er aus.
Schrötlich-braunlich, oder?
Rot-braun, ja.
Haben Sie auch Blut bemerkt?
Blut habe ich nicht gesehen, nein.
Okay.
Und ist diese Atemnot auch neu seit ein paar Tagen oder schon vorher?
Die Atemnot habe ich ein bisschen, aber ist seit heute richtig schlimm geworden, ja.
Seit heute Morgen, die Atemnot, ja.
Okay.
Haben Sie das Fieber schon gemessen?
Also, die im Heim haben es gemessen, es waren ungefähr 39,5.
Ich wohne im Altenheim, wissen Sie, da haben die messen die immer.
Und die haben auch Corona-Tests und so, das machen die immer.
Aber die waren negativ jetzt.
Hm, ja.
Die Schelltest.
Ja, negativ.
Ich habe auch jetzt hier, wie Sie sehen können, auch ein Fieberbläschen bekommen seit vorgestern.
Fieberbläschen.
Und ich habe auch so, wenn ich tief atme, tut es mir unten weh, im Oberbauch auch manchmal.
Ich kann nicht so tief einatmen.
Beim Einatmen?
Ja.
Okay.
Und Herr Doktor, ich muss noch sagen, vielleicht haben Sie die Unterlange.
Ich war ja schon im Krankenhaus vor 10 Tagen wegen auch wieder Fieber.
Hatte ich auch Fieber gehabt.
Aber da haben die Ärzte festgestellt, dass ich eine Blaseninfekt hatte wegen meiner Prostateilfekrösung.
Und da habe ich ein Krankenhausantibiotika bekommen.
Hm, und eisige.
Vor 10 Tagen ungefähr war das.
Okay.
Die andere Abteilung.
Ja, ja, ich habe verstanden, sind diese Verschwerden schon weg?
Die sind weg, ja.
Also beim Wasserlassen habe ich keine Probleme jetzt.
Ah, okay.
Ja, Herr Hitzfeld, haben Sie einen Auslöser für diese Beschwerden bemerkt?
Welche Beschwerden meinen Sie jetzt als Auslöser?
Ich meine, ja, allgemein, Husten, Fieberarten, Nord, oder haben Sie einen Auslöser bemerkt?
Hm, kann ich so nicht sagen, nein.
Es gibt etwas, dass diese Beschwerden lehnt oder verschlecht hat.
Kann ich jetzt so nicht sagen.
Wenn ich viel rede, habe ich mehr Luftnoten.
Das stimmt, ja.
Wenn Sie hinbekommen.
Das Gespräch mit Ihnen strengt mich schon an.
Also, da habe ich schon Luftnoten, wie Sie merken.
Hm.
Okay, ich mache meine Notizen.
Ja.
Erleben Sie, Sie sollten Beschwerden das erste Mal oder ist das neu für Sie?
Zum Beispiel Atemnot.
Haben Sie normalerweise Atemnot?
Nein, kann, habe ich normalerweise nicht.
Und Husten?
Auch nicht?
Auch nicht, nein.
Hm.
Okay.
Also, okay.
Herr Hitzfeld, haben Sie noch andere Beschwerden?
Haben Sie noch etwas über den Gewöhn?
Ich habe es bemerkt.
Nein, das sind die wichtigsten Sachen, die ich bemerkt habe.
Okay.
Können Sie gut schlafen?
Also, jetzt seit zwei Tagen nicht,
aber sonst habe ich keine Probleme gehabt.
Okay.
Und in diesen zwei Tagen, was ist der Grund,
ist das herrlich?
Ja, das ist ja ein schlitzendes Fieber.
Wirst du apetit?
Ist jetzt auch schlecht.
Seit zwei Tagen, meine Sie?
Ja, seitdem der Husten angefangen ist,
ist das apetit nicht so gut.
Ja, okay.
Haben Sie in letzter Zeit ab- oder zugenommen?
Ich habe mich nicht gewogen, ich kann Sie nichts sagen.
Ja, die passen, die Altekleiden noch?
Ja, die passen noch, ja.
Haben Sie irgendwelche Probleme beim Wasserlasten oder Stuhlgang?
Also Wasserlasten habe ich immer Probleme schon die ganze Zeit,
ich habe eine Brust, da ist das größer auch.
Ja.
Deswegen habe ich da Probleme ein bisschen,
aber das ist jetzt nichts Neues.
Ja.
Aber schon ein paar Jahre schon.
Ich verstehe.
Und beim Stuhlgang?
Ja, beim Stuhlgang kann ich nicht sagen, da das Probleme sind.
Ich meine, die Farbe, die Barschafeneid, alles in Ordnung?
Ist mir nichts aufgefallen.
Okay.
Sind Sie vorständig?
Herr Hitzl.
Haben Sie mal gegen Corona?
Gegen Corona und auch gegen Kinderkrankheiten.
Oh, das weiß ich nicht mehr, das ist schon so lange her.
Gegen Corona habe ich drei Impfungen,
aber die anderen weiß ich nicht genau.
Ich kann auch Ihren Ausfall halten, kein Problem.
Waren Sie in letzter Zeit im Ausland?
Nein, ich kann nicht mehr so gut laufen, ich bin im Heim und mache keine Auslandsreise mehr.
Ja.
Also Herr Hitzl, Sie haben schon erwähnt,
dass Sie Prostativergrößerung haben.
Und leiden Sie noch andere Vorerkrankungen?
Ja, ich hatte vor zehn Jahren so etwas ähnlich wie ein Herzenfakt.
Und dann hat man so ein Krankenhaus-Katheter gemacht und dann gesagt,
dass meine Blutgefäße im Herzen verschlossen sind
und hat dann mich zur Operation geschickt.
Ich habe eine Beipass-Operation bekommen.
Und dann letztes Jahr habe ich auch nochmal so Schwerten gehabt,
dann so Druckgefühl gehabt,
hat man einmal Herz-Katheter gemacht
und dann hat man noch einen Stand gesetzt letztes Jahr nochmal.
Ansonsten habe ich Bluthochdruck
und seit einigen Jahren auch Zucker.
Ich starte in der Phase 2, wie ist denn Sie?
Also ich spritze Insulin abends.
Ich weiß nicht genau.
Nehmen Sie auch Tabletten ein?
Hatte ich früher mal jetzt nicht mehr.
Hat man Arzt-Haushalts-Ungestellt auf Insulin,
das ist nur noch abends.
So Insulin haben Sie seit wann? Leiden Sie an Bluthochdruck?
Ich muss auch schon seit zehn Jahren bestimmt schon,
bei dem ich diesen Herzenfakt hatte.
Aber diese Trückerkrankheit seit zwei Jahren?
Auch ungefähr, auch ungefähr so.
Das war ungefähr die gleiche Zeit.
Das war zehn Jahre, würde ich sagen.
Also Herr Hitzfeld,
sind Sie schon mal operiert vor so?
Ich meine, dieser Weifers habe ich schon notiert.
Ansonsten? Ansonsten hatte ich keine Operation bisher.
Sind bei Ihnen gegen welche Allergien bekannt?
Ja, ich habe eine Penizidenallergie.
Da hatte ich mal vor vielen Jahren mal
einen starken Hautausschlag bekommen.
Okay.
Ich habe geraucht, aber seit zehn Jahren auch nicht mehr.
Ich habe davor schon aufgehört, wenn ich es sage.
Also ich habe bis, glaube ich, 60 Jahre alt,
da habe ich aufgehört.
Ja, das ist sehr schön.
Aber vorher, wie viel ungefähr habe ich?
Ich meine, für wie viele Jahre,
wie viele sind die über 18 ungefähr?
Ich habe vielleicht mit so 18, 20 angefangen,
ungefähr 40 Jahre, würde ich sagen.
Halbe, halbe Spektion, ein Spektion, oder so?
Also maximal ein Spektion,
das war auch zuletzt vielleicht nur ein halbes Spektion,
aber überwiegend ein Spektion, würde ich sagen.
Okay, ja. Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Nicht mehr, ich habe früher mal ein bisschen getrunken,
aber seit vielen Jahren trinkt ich dann Alkohol mehr.
Das ist gut, ja, Herr Hitzberg.
Bitte nehmen Sie die folgende Frage nicht über,
aber nehmen Sie Drogen, oder haben Sie schon probiert?
Nein, habe ich noch nie probiert.
Wie ist Ihr Familienstand?
Ich bin Witwer, meine Frau ist verstorben vor 7, 8 Jahren.
Kannst du damit klarkommen?
Ja, ich bin jetzt leider im Pflegeheim,
weil niemanden habe der auf mich aufpassen kann,
ich bin nicht mehr körperlich so gesund.
Deswegen bin ich seit ungefähr 3, 4 Jahren im Pflegeheim.
Ich habe keine Kinder, deswegen.
Keine Kinder, das ist auch so.
4 Jahre im Pflegeheim, keine Kinder.
Sie sind schon im Rente, ja?
Ja.
Was haben Sie per Üblichte am Markt?
Beim Autohausgearbeit habe ich Autos verkauft.
Also Autokaufware, ja, oder? Verkäufer.
Autoferkäufer kann man sagen, ja.
Treiben Sie Sport?
Nein, ich bin nicht mehr so gesund für Sport.
Siehen ja, ich kann nicht mehr so gut laufen.
Ja, okay.
Also Herr Hitzer, gibt es wichtige Krankheiten in Ihren nahen Verwandtschaften?
Ich meine, Ihre Eltern oder Geschwister?
Das kann ich nicht sagen, ich bin Weisenkind.
Deswegen habe ich keine Verwandten.
Ja, aber zum Beispiel Ihr Vater, Ihre Mutter?
Ja, ich bin als kleines Kind ins Heim gekommen, als Weisenkind.
Ich kenne meinen Vater und meine Mutter nicht.
Ach ja, ich weiß nicht mehr.
Wie war Ihr Krieg?
Ich habe sie auf richtig nicht reicht.
Ich war in Krieg, ich bin im Krieg geboren.
Ich weiß nicht, was meine Eltern, ob sie gestorben sind oder nicht.
Das weiß ich nicht mehr.
Ach ja, ich verstehe.
Herr Hitzer, ich habe alle wichtigen Fragen von meiner Seite gestellt.
Ich werde Sie jetzt über die weitere Schritte informieren.
Möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Wollen Sie noch meinen Medikamentliste haben?
Ja, natürlich.
Das haben die mitgegeben im Krieg gereimt.
Die machen die Tabletten für mich immer.
Genau, wir werden die Medikamente nehmen.
Die letzte, ich lese die Tablette mal vor.
Einmal das ASS, 100, die nehme ich morgens ein.
Dann nehme ich noch Plavix, 75, eine morgens.
Dann habe ich das Ramipri, 5 mg Mittags.
Dann habe ich Atovastatin, 20, abends, Dordart.
Für die Brosse nehme ich abends 1, 1,5 kg.
Und ich spritze noch abends Insulin-Lantus, 14 Einheiten.
Die Dordis, Sie könnten Sie wiederholen, vor Landus?
14 Einheiten.
14, ja.
Und die Dordis auch für Dordart?
Das weiß ich nicht, ich habe die nicht aufgeschrieben.
Eine Tablette, eine Kapsel.
Eine Kapsel, ja.
Gut.
Haben Sie alle Fragen gestellt, die Sie stellen wollten?
Gibt es noch andere Fragen von den Zuhörern, die Sie gefragt hätten?
Bevor diese Beschwerden beginnen,
wie viele Stufen können Sie zeigen, bevor Sie Luftnot haben
oder ich stehen bleiben?
Ich kann keine Stufen zeigen, ich habe meine Beine,
die sind zu schwach.
Ich kann keine Treppen steigen.
Können Sie auf dem Rücken schlafen, bevor diese Beschwerden beginnen?
Ja, konnte ich.
Haben Sie Herzrasen, Stolpern oder?
Hab ich nicht bemerkt.
Haben Sie geschöne Beine?
Ist mir nicht aufgefallen, keine, nein.
Und diese Heimat, andere Freunde,
gleich Beschwerden haben?
Im Heim meinen Sie?
Im Heim? Pflegeheim? Keine anderen, die so ein paar über haben.
Danke.
Okay, weitere Fragen?
Wie hoch?
39,5.
Wie viele Kiste brauchen Sie beim Schlafen?
Eins, ein normales Kisten.
Ich glaube, das waren die wichtigsten Fragen.
Diese Fragen, normal oder nicht, eine Frage.
Im Krankenhaus,
die Erachterung durchführen,
zum Beispiel, die Echokardiografie,
das weiß er nicht mehr,
er weiß nur, dass vor zehn Tagen wegen einer Harnweckinfektion
mit Fieber im Krankenhaus war.
Das weiß er nicht.
Haben Sie missgesagt?
Immer.
Ich möchte zuerst sagen,
dass es eine sehr dicke Nefestarlöhe gibt.
Ich habe keine Reaktionen,
Sorge ich nur, ich weiß nicht, wie ich es sage.
Mani, 20 Minuten.
Ich schaue dir jetzt mal,
ob wir uns das in der Sattration sehen.
Wir müssen das sagen,
oder wir müssen das sagen.
Das wäre gut, wenn Sie sagen,
ich messe mal ganz kurz in Sauerstoff,
gerade im Boot, mit gutem Oxymeter am Finger.
Das gibt es ja mittlerweile überall.
Dann würde ich dann entsprechend sagen,
ok, dann geben wir Ihnen ein bisschen Sauerstoff,
bis wir weiter reden.
Das wäre gut, wenn man das machen würde.
Wir haben uns unterwischen,
ja, wir haben uns über die Schere, die wir haben.
Über die Schere oder die Schere.
Mit welchem Antibiotikum wurden Sie behandelt?
Weiß ich nicht.
Er hat Infusion bekommen im Krankenhaus,
kann er nicht sagen.
Hab ich Sie narsenlauf?
Narsenlaufen,
bisschen Schnupfen hat er ja.
Ok, dann würde ich sagen,
gehen wir zur Vorstellung,
das wird ja noch ein paar Minuten.
Ja, ja.
1-2 Minuten,
1-2 Minuten, Herr Kollege.
Muss er da sein?
Ja, ich mache es.
Wie war der erste Entschließung von Muhammed?
Ich war sehr zufrieden.
Mein erstes Entschließung war sehr kurz.
Muhammed, ist es ein Urgün?
Ja, es war gut.
Ich habe wieder Muhammed
in seinem Entschließung geschrieben,
ich kann es nicht trinken,
ich bin momentan belongingsabende,
ich bin physisch da,
Kurstungauglauf,
ich bin phys części da,
ich bin für die Zuständigung,
ich bin für die Zuständigkeit,
ich bin strokeswedis ich bin für die ketchupen
» unpμο am en »
Car.
»
Ja, sehr gut.
Ein sehr schnelles Entwurf,
der Zeitumgang ist nicht verliebt.
Wir haben 19-Jährige,
und wir haben eine sehr schnelles Entwurf.
Ja.
Ein weiterer Becher,
aber ich habe es nicht verstanden.
Nein.
Aber warum fragen Sie?
Ich würde verstehen,
ob Sie besonders bei Eurofadings und so weiter ein Problem haben.
Hm, okay.
Aber hat das mit den Symptomen etwas zu tun?
Also ich würde auch jetzt nicht zu viele Sachen fragen,
die nichts mit den Symptomen zu tun haben.
Verstehen Sie?
Wir können auch fragen,
haben Sie Schmerzen,
wenn ich in die Wartedrücke zum Beispiel, ja?
Kann man auch fragen,
hat mit den Symptomen nichts zu tun?
Ich kann auch fragen.
Ich kann anfangen.
Bitte schön.
Ja, guten Tag Herr Oberarzt.
Ich möchte Ihnen einen neuen Patient
in Vorstellenshausen,
die Kurzzeitzeit.
Bitte schön.
Herr Otmar Hitzfeld,
77-jähriger Patient,
ist 1,75 Meter groß
und 65 kg schwer.
Herr Hitzfeld klagt über
gestern Nacht aufgetretene Fieber- und Schüttefrost.
Das Fieber ist
39,5 Grad.
Er leitet
auch an
seit 3, 4 Tagen
bestehende,
Tagebestehende,
Dyschnöre und
produktive Tussis.
Tussis.
Ja.
Die Dyschnöre
hat
heute schlimmer geworden.
Die Dyschnöre hat zugenommen heute,
oder ist es nicht mehr geworden?
Ja, hat zugenommen und ja,
ist es nicht mehr geworden.
Die Farbe des Ausrufs
sei
jötlich braun.
Er hatte schon
Corona-Test.
Er habe schon Corona-Test gemacht
und das Ergebnis
ist negativ,
sei negativ.
Dann hat er angegeben,
dass er
Schmerzen
bei der Inspiration hat.
Tokakali Schmerzen
und etwas auch Abobach Schmerzen.
Ja.
Übrigens meldet er
ja.
Ja.
Übrigens
meldet er
eine
Krankenhaus
vor 10 Tagen
im Krankenhaus behandelt wurde
wegen
einer Handwerksinfektion.
Er berichtete darüber,
dass er vor 10 Tagen
in Kargenhaus behandelt wurde.
Genau.
Sollte er beschwerden
er lebt
sie das erste Mal
im Leben.
Die vegetative Anamnese
ist
die übrige vegetative Anamnese
ist unabhängig bis auf
Inapetenz
und leichter Insomni
seit 2 Tagen.
Anvor Erkrankungen
leidet er
Prostata hyperpulasi.
Arteriale Hepatoni
seit 10 Jahren
und Diabetes mellitus
wahrscheinlich
Typ 1 oder
seit 10 Jahren.
Typ 2 normalerweise.
2, okay.
Er nimmt
100 mg
einmal täglich
und morgens
Klavix
20 mg
einmal morgens
5 mg
einmal abends
20 mg
Donat
1 Tablette
und Diabetes ist nicht erinnerlich
Landhof
Units
am Abend
Wir sind Einheiten, ja.
Bei den Patienten
erfolgt
eine Beifahrtoperation
vor 10 Jahren
und eine
Stand-Implantation
am Herz
vor 1 Jahr auch.
Bei ihm ist
penicillin allergie bekannt
er reagiert darauf
mit Extantem.
Er ist
momentan nicht traucher
aber
vorher
gibt es 40
Paxonia-Nikotin-Konsum
Er trinkt
keine Alkohol-Drogenkonsum
wurde verneint.
Er ist
seit 5 Jahren verwidert
und
er lebt in einem Pflegeheim
er hat keine Kinder
er ist momentan im Rente
und vorher
war er Autoverkäufer
von Beruf
er treibt keinen Sport
und die Familienanamnese
ist unbekannt
Ja, Herr Oberhardt
meine Verdachtsdiagnose
ist
Pynämonie
als die Finanziadiagnose
kommen in
Betracht
leicht
ja
Piloritis
Pericarditis
Ja, das weiß
Wichtigsten, ja, okay
Was
würden Sie jetzt als nächstes tun?
Ja
Um die Diagnose
stellen wir
um die Diagnose
Stellung zu können
würde ich zuerst die
Vitalparameter überprüfen
Ja
Da erwarte ich
Fieber, vielleicht auch
Pericarditis
und
Pericarditis auch möglich
wegen Dysne
dann würde ich
deren Patienten
stölperlich untersuchen
bei der Inspektion
kann ich
Dysne
und Arterersatz von Atem
Hilfmuskulatur
entdecken
Vielleicht auch Diagnose
und
ja
Erzählen Sie mal, was über die Auskotations
befunden war
Diagnose
Ja, da erwarte ich Rasselgeräusche
Was für Rasselgeräusche?
Ist das
fein oder?
Ja, fein
Fein
Jetzt
2 Arten von Rasselgeräuschen
wissen Sie, wie man die einteilt, ganz grob
können Sie sie wieder holen?
Es gibt so eine grobe Einteilung
von Rasselgeräuschen
in 2 große Gruppen
2 große Gruppen, die ich meine
Karbon,
in der
ich liebe
Aber in Deutsch
feine und
grobblasig
Aber ich meine etwas anderes
Bevor man diese
feinblasig
Beim Exploration
oder Inspiration
könnte
auch bei die Atemgeräusche meistens
die Inspiration zu hören sind
also das, was Sie hören
Aber haben Sie schon mal gehört
trockene und feuchte Rasselgeräusche?
Nein, ich habe nicht gehört
Ich denke immer, Rasselgeräusche
sind verbunden mit
feuchten Gewürben
Ne, es gibt
Einteilung der Rasselgeräusche
in feuchte Rasselgeräusche
Hauptsächlich
bei Prämonie beispielsweise
oder auch zum Beispiel beim Lungen
mit dem, da sind die auch feucht
Sie meinen nicht
mit dem, da sind die
oder mit dem
ich meine das aus Kutation
feuchte Rasselgeräusche
und trockene Rasselgeräusche
Trockene Rasselgeräusche
gehören, was Sie eben gesagt haben
Grummen
Giemen
Pfeifen zum Beispiel
Ja, das sind die trockene Rasselgeräusche
und die feuchten Rasselgeräusche
sind diese feinblasigen
grobblasigen Rasselgeräuschen
die meistens bei Prämonie oder anderen
alveolan Störungen auftreten
und andere sind meistens
Geräusche, die von den
Bräunchen der Bräunchen-Johlen ausgehen
Spastik und so was
also trockene und feuchte Rasselgeräusche
Was erwarten Sie jetzt
bei einer Prämonie für Rasselgeräusche?
Ja, feuchte
feuchte Rasselgeräusche
und oft dann feinblasig dann, ja
Ja, vom
Ja
Rasselgeräusche
feinblasig, ja
Gut, jetzt haben Sie ja ausguckt
Sie hören die Rasselgeräusche, was machen Sie als nächstes?
Dann würde ich
ihm Blut abnehmen
Ja
Wo nachgucken Sie ihm Blut dann?
Blut ist wichtig
ob es Lokosytose gibt
Und
ein Zunuchsparameter auch wichtig
Ja, das ist das wichtigste
Ja
Was machen Sie noch?
Dann würde ich
einen
Sputumkultur anzüchten
Okay, können Sie machen
Ja, dauert halt meistens
ein paar Tage bis da etwas wechseln
oder Sie bekommen den Befund nicht sofort
Ja, zuerst plane ich mit
einem
mit einer
panphädischen Therapie
Wir sind noch bei der Diagnostik
Was machen Sie noch? Was schnell geht
und haben Sie auch einen guten Ergebnis bekommen?
Weitere Diagnostische
Maßnahmen
Ja, ich würde auch
EKG veranlassen
Ja, das macht man auch
Gut
Können Sie im EKG
verstehen, ob es ein Pneumonie ist?
Nein, ich meine
um eine
Gesamtleinruf zu bekommen
Peresproblem auszuschliessen
Aber wie können Sie die Pneumonie noch Diagnostizieren?
Natürlich
Das ist wichtig
Wisst ihr da, was man da normalerweise
sieht bei einer normalen Pneumonie?
Normaler Pneumonie
Beidseitige
Basale
Infiltrationen
Die Infiltrate können überall sein
Die können beidseitig sein, die einen sein
Die müssen nicht basale sein, sie sehen Infiltrate
Infiltrationen, ja
Wie sind die oft Infiltrate?
Noch mal bitte
Wie sind die
typischerweise
Infiltrate?
Wie sehen die aus?
Wie sehen aus
wie
Infiltrationen
Aber wie sehen aus?
Kennen Sie den Unterschied
zwischen typischer und atypischer Pneumonie?
Ja, atypischer
Im Zusammenhang
von
Schöntgen-Torax
Das typische Bild bei der Pneumonie
Das klassisches Bild
bei der Pneumonie
Sie sehen seine Verschattung
Wie ist die Verschattung oft?
Auf welchem Bereich ist sie begrenzt?
Basale oder nicht?
Kann sein
Aber wie nennt man es so?
Wie ist es oft?
Meistens auf einen Lappen beschränkt
Also, Laubere
Ja, dener
Auf einen Lappen begrenzt oft
Weil der Kind nicht immer so ist
Typischerweise ist es Laubere
Und das ist dann eine typische
Lauberepneumonie
Wohingegen atypische Pneumonien
Nichts Lauberees Bild haben
Auf eine Fleckiges Muster haben
Und dann auch
Vardilorisch auch andere form-
reticuläre Zeichnungen zum Beispiel
Meistens kann man noch
einen CT machen
Also
dann machen wir ganz kurz noch die Therapie
Haben Sie gesagt, was Sie geben wollten?
Therapie ist
zuerst
würde ich diesen Patienzen
stationär aufnehmen
weil
er ist ja
etwas zu alt
Ja
Und die Therapie
ist hauptsächlich ein
Antibiotikomtherapie
Richtig, ja
Aber welches Antibiotikum
das weiß ich nicht
genau, wo mehr nicht zu sein
Okay, gibt es ja
einen Unterschied bei den Patienten
wie sie die Antibiotikatherapie wählen
oder
wie teilt man die Antipneumonie
noch ein?
Eine Einteilung haben wir gesagt
typische atypische Pneumonie
Wo oft die typischen Bakterien sind
und die atypischen eher viral
aber es ist nicht immer so
nur oft
und dann gibt es noch eine andere Einteilung
die man noch macht
um auch das Risiko
abzuschätzen
für den Patienten
können Sie sich darin erinnern, was man da noch macht
und Einteilung
Meinerweise
als eine
Krankheit oder für Therapie
Beides
Also
wo die Patienten herkommen
oder wo sie die Pneumonie bekommen haben
ist das wichtig?
Ja, natürlich
Kennen Sie die
Einteilung, die man dann macht?
Es gab ja
gesellschaftliche Pneumonie
oder
nur so komicale Pneumonie
Wie nennt man das noch? Also nur so komicale ist richtig
wie nennt man diese andere, das erste, was Sie genannt haben
noch allgemein
gesellschaftlich, sondern
folglich, infolk der Quelle
man merkt dann oft
ambulant aber auch eine Pneumonie
das andere ist nur so komicale
und das hat dann auch
Einfluss auf die Waldeantibiotika
Was macht man normalerweise für eine Antibiotiktherapie
ganz grob, egal welche Einteilung
Was gibt man da?
Meistens
Weitere Antibiotikung
Welches gibt man da am meisten?
Ich kann das nicht gerne aber
ich kann es dann
Aminopädicillin gibt man gerne
Ja
und wenn der
Handgefaktoren hat, kann man noch
Metallaktamase in die Beton dazu geben
aber Erdia ist eine Penicillinallergie
Also können Sie
jetzt erst mal keinen Amoxicillin oder Amoxipäen
oder wie auch immer geben
oder was würden Sie dann alternativ geben
Zerfallosporin vielleicht
Kann man probieren, ja
Ist richtig, was noch?
Makrolide
Hier nichts
Es gibt eine
Levofluxacin
Das ist
Fluxinolone
Levofluxacin
Nicht mehr mittel der ersten Walder
Okay
Ich habe das nicht zu tun
Ich habe den Chat nicht beachtet
damit wenn ich durcheinander komme
Segment der Lobären
Lobären ist etwas redipulär
Man muss immer einen Risikofaktor
denken ob es Patienten
die Risiko haben
für multirestente Erreger zum Beispiel
und vor allem wenn der Patient
vor einem Krankenhaus war
vor 10 Tagen
hat der Risiko das auch
multirestente Erreger hat
war halt an die Bioliker beachten
Okay
dann war das
ziemlich viel für den Fall
ich habe ziemlich geboort
über die
als Oberarzt glaube ich
Pascal